damn come on Pam on yahwah's goodest
dumbfounded I'm moving on a bigger
things big bank tag little Bank bout to
the MS account what and this is the
first week these sessions in Koreatown
and we're gonna make a Korean pancakes
and this is different this is different
the same with the sear of this thing
with the top things like bananas what we
got in this one we got vegetables
jalapeno steamed pork kimchi that's
gonna cure the hangover quick so before
first we feast first we drink let's go
to the blog put the deed in your broad
line first few feet we start to me with
your pancakes and like anything anywhere
which is out to me about Kate I always
say like probably love it that's what
sub that it really helped me eat free
meals for five years but we're gonna do
what you know really well which is
appacha hi Jenna is a savory pancake
there are two styles of pancakes in
Korea basically ping dead duck and my
jump
margin is like a chewy R almost doughy
right
it's a lot let's build this painting
once you tell freestyle on it
yo kimchi let that marinate in the
batter like the swim team yeah you throw
in a little pig feet and you put a
little flick of the wrist with the
vegetable [ __ ] he's a chef to the right
with the sesame let's let us see what he
does with that sprinkles it on let
ecstasy and little hint the salt a
little hint of malt and a sprinkle on
the bladder let it porn poor not porn
but it looks like food porn not what you
can get at a k-town food court this is
Los Angeles Koreatown not New York it's
more than one Street there you go mix it
all in apply the heat and then just take
a seat
that's a dipping sauce yeah I love that
it has a chili powder a salted shrimp
salted shrimp yeah that's the what adds
that flavor yeah green onions ginger
garlic soy it's a really like potent
sauce I tell people don't don't soak it
in it you know you don't need too much
of it
I could hear the voice of my ancestors
whispering you know the same they're
saying I'm proud I'm proud of you
well after a long couple of hours
vigorous hours of working on this
excellent pancake which we named this
thing man I was freestyling off the dome
so let's do a little play on words with
freestyle off the dough off the dough
there you go okay off the dough pancake
available at pot restaurant for the next
whip all October all October or first
week piece you know pot restaurant Roy
always a pleasure love them hate them
first we feast
this is the Korean Jesus believe us we'd
a real deal so take a chill pill got the
homie with the flick of the wrist
flipping up pancakes this is like a
morning mandate you know we just having
a meal